l'union européenne ne sera plus tout à
fait la même après la présidence
française c'est ce qu'a affirmé ce matin
jacques chirac devant le parlement de
strasbourg
sa priorité reste la réforme des
institutions européennes
une priorité qui suscite toujours la
même opposition chez les souverainistes
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
véronique saint olive et jean-paul
chaussée c'est parti pour six mois
la france préside l'union européenne et
jacques chirac conduit à se poser en
leader 10 à vis des autres chefs d'état
et de gouvernement pour occuper le
premier plan international et tout
l'espace politique intérieure le
président de la république c'est aussi
que la réussite française repose d'abord
sur une harmonie affichée avec lionel
jospin la france parlera donc d'une
seule voix
réformer les institutions avant l'entrée
de nouveaux membres c'est l'une des
priorités affirmé ce matin qui ont
toutes été définis élaborer ensemble
mais une fois encore jacques chirac veut
dépasser le strict calendrier façon de
se démarquer du premier ministre de se
positionner sur le long terme
le débat sur l'avenir de l'europe ainsi
été relancé et il y a tout lieu de s'en
réjouir tant il est nécessaire dans les
périodes décisives de regarder un peu
plus loin que les échéances où les
préoccupations immédiates de fixer le
cap
les socialistes ne bronchent même si
charles pasqua qui est à la vérité la
vérité madame la présidente monsieur le
président en exercice de l'union
européenne
c'est que cette europe est et restera
condamné à la fuite en avant
tant qu'elle persistera se penser comme
d'essence supérieure aux nations qui la
composent et par conséquent destinée
tout ou tard à les remplacer en lançant
l'idée d'une constitution européenne
jacques chirac a voulu apparaître comme
plus dynamique et plus moderne que son
premier ministre lionel jospin a répondu
en naviguant qui lui s'en tiendrait au
dossier concret mais ce matin le
président de la république a enfoncé une
fois de plus le clou